Now that we've seen some of the most common types of charts and
learned about how the grammar of graphics helps us separate data from our
visual representation of that data.
I want to show you to how to put this theory into practice using D-3 and
Associate Technologies.
As covered in Lesson One.
The visualization stack for different technologies can go pretty deep.
At the top of this spectrum, we have graphical tools such as RAW or Excel.
They let us very quickly and easily create predefined charts for
our data, but lack flexibility.
At the low end of the spectrum are technologies like Canvas, WebGL, and
SVG itself.
These low level tools at the bottom of the spectrum are the most flexible but
give you an interface similar to a painter.
You must specify pixels and
colors to do something even as simple as drawing a line.
And just forget about making dynamic charts and binding data.
Since we will be working somewhere in the middle of this spectrum when working
with charts, I do not yet want to deal with all the complexities of raw D3.
D3 is often confused for a charting library, when in fact
they exist at one level lower and also one level below the grammar of graphics.
And think of D3 as the building blocks that someone might use if they want to
create a charting library with Excel-like plotting functionality.
And that is exactly what many people have done.
We will be using a library called Dimple.js for the slide coding example.
It's implemented on top of D3,
which in turn is implemented on top of SVG, JavaScript, and HTML.
And provides us a very nice abstraction for building charts, and allows us to
think in the way that we might want to when concerning the grammar of graphics.